ANALYSIS.E BEEN GIVEN BACK ISEEL
EVANTH MUCH.
I WANTAIGHT NOW TO  THE
STNT'SEL
E NS INTLLARY
D GENE
PELING OF CLASFI
U EAYOU'VE INVESTIGATED SIR AKI.
ES FORARTMENT OF  T
ES WT
DISCLOSURE OF SENSITIVCLASSI IOO
IJUSTTHRANT DISREGARD ANDTHAT,I
NG TO ME,
HAVING OVERSEC OENDANTS UNDER I
LEVELL AA FOUNDATION FOR A CH E
TATES.
>> I MEAN THERE .
YOE D
O STOP FOR A
TO ASK U  DAVIDGOS LIST.'S HERS
PROPERTY.
THE FBI TOOK FROM TRME.
ALL IN SETID, OFASSIFIEDOCTHEM .
ONE WI TY SPECIA
DESIGNATIOECIVTM
T TO YOU ON THIS LISTELL,H VOLU
LEVEL OF SENSITIVITY
RMTALKING ABOULTF TO I
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE UNITED.
AND THENTHAT W
CR
I MEAN THOSE ARE DOCUMENTS TD OS
MOST TYPICALLYC PEE COMMUNICATIT
ACTIVITIES OACTIVITIES.MALD, SO
THREGIOUS.
INFORMATION.
WAS TAKEN,T TO BE  K
WE KNOW A LOT BEC
YOU'VE GOT THIS LIST, BUKNOW EXY
SHLDE GNT THE DETAILS
FROM WHAT YOU OWE FBSAS  S OF T
EN IN THE SOMEWHATOPAQUE REC O
COMPLYE NT'SO THE
VALIDATETE THAT PROB TSEARCH.Y W
GOVERNMENT'S IESO
E PRESIDENULING CLSIINFORMATIONL
MAR-A-LAGO.
KN
INVESTIGATIOTRANOR
OUOSECUTION
RETO BN AL WHETHER
IS LOOKING IE VATING.ITH REGARDT
HOOLUMCLASSIFIEDORINPLACE IT WAN
ORAS, IN WHAS OF PLACES  ACCESS
THTHERE,